um
but we're going to go back to the
katakatama
seminar okay
all right
so
uh if i'm going to attack an arm as in
katakatame
there's a couple of things one i have to
isolate the arm
it can't be
so defendable with the other arm or his
body or something like that and two
uh i don't
i don't grab the arm
the arm lands in the trap
okay so uh
let's say
um
for example
uh he's in my closed guard right
and uh he's trying to work something
right
and he's i don't do whatever okay so
here
uh
i'll i did the knee pull
do you see
and this arm i can start to isolate it
as i shield the other arm
from
with my body do you see that
and then this is the trap
i'm not going to grab it i'm in the trap
it's how i cap the arm and then i can
find the technique
over here
likewise
i'm going to isolate his arm
and then i'm going to create a trap
and then the fly lands in the trap i do
not grab the arm okay
so in kihon maza
unlike in that example i'm not isolating
the arm by shielding it with my body
i'm going to isolate the arm
with a
uh
shikaku
this
you see
you can do it in gross movements of
course
it's isolated now
and you can do it in with your cochlear
projector
it's isolated now okay
so that's the first thing when we do the
isolation
we're always going to take him into this
front inward kazushi because it
generates the angle cancellation on the
other arm
which isolates this one okay
so i'm not going to do a kazushi this
way
i want the angle cancellation
and there's the arm
okay so that's our first part isolate
the arm with the angle of cancellation
using a coq projection okay
so there are many trapping models
but the key basic one you want are these
open-ended triangles okay
uh so if you paid attention
when i was here and i came around move
out of the way
that was the trap that's my open-ended
triangles okay it could be this way it
could be this way
that is the
best way
of
creating a trap
which means as a trap what it means is i
don't chase the thing the thing lands in
the trap okay
so uh as i isolate the arm
this hand goes
right here okay
don't
try to grab the arm
so i'm gonna do the trap
boom
over the top
do it again
boom
this hand goes this way
and there's the trap
okay
don't squeeze it yet
move around you're gonna have to come
around
as i move around so it looks kind of
parallel right now do you see
but as i move around
there it is right there
okay
and as we
continue to circle
it's getting tighter
and in place
now do it again
boom
isolate
trap
here it's not quite there
as you move around there it is
and it keeps
now closing in
on itself
most of you understand this part because
you're used to grabbing him
so i'm going to focus in on this part
what this arm does this arm goes this
way
this argument is this
boom
in yield
trap don't close yet
turn and it'll close
resist
grabbing the arm
let the arm be a fly and your uh venus
fly trap okay let it fall into it